I swear it feels like there's a gay Jin
in the corner hoping that I open up that
website and do
it by the grace of Allah subhah wa
ta'ala the response has been
overwhelming to say the very least
alhamdulillah we've had social media
personalities and respected Scholars sh
from many parts of the Muslim world
promoting the cause we have raised
almost 1.4 million alhamdulillah and we
haven't been sitting idy waiting to hit
our Target of 2 million we have fully
purchased four properties in London
transferred their ownership to the W
after the help of Allah subhanahu wa
taala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves we encourage you to stay
tuned for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly underway asalam
Alum guys you guys might be aware of son
Faz son Faz is somebody I spoke to with
his mom as well um both lovely
individuals I spoke to him as a
non-muslim and if I'm not mistaken he's
a Muslim alhamd may Allah subhana
preserve him and protect him
alhamdulillah after all Palestine thing
many people are coming to Islam this one
of the hias and the beauty of the
situation Subhan Allah many many things
are coming out but alhamd people are
flocking to Islam even in a DA table
people are flocking to Islam and
Palestine plays a key role in that
because people see how strong they are
Subhan Allah they children been blown up
to pieces and they're still saying
alhamd so people want to know who is the
Lord that they worship that makes them
so strong now son when I spoke to him he
lovely guy alhamd was giving him da to
him and his mom here's a video of him
talking about obviously himself how he
stopped masturbating watching
pornography and all that kind of
degenerate stuff aldah and Islam comes
to purify that and Muslims and you know
Subhan Allah myself as a disbeliever I
was exposed to certain things I didn't
want to see and it destroys the soul
pornography destroys one's soul brothers
and sisters so here's a video of him
talking about his experience or him him
believing that there is some kind of a
gay or homosexual genin uh in in
his he feels that you know anytime he
watches stuff so let's listen for
ourselves cuz I find it very interesting
and what lessons we can learn on how to
protect ourself from gin and from the
Mankind and the Gin kind and we we can
not a little bit more about the Gins in
here's the video what was the most
shocking thing you learned about Islam
after taking your shahada good question
I would say that God created two free
willed beings humans and Jin that really
took me for a rocker was realizing that
there's free will Jin out out there
where their purpose is also to worship
God but they have the choice not to and
they're going to be judged just like we
will that one took me for a loop and I'm
telling you that helped me to like quit
po like not just quit porn but quit like
just masturbating and like lust in
general cuz it feels like every single
time I want to do that it's like there's
like a gay gin in my room hoping that I
do I wah that's what I think and maybe
that's weird but I swear it feels like
there's a gayin in the corner hoping
that I open up that website and do it
and I won't ever no disgusting and even
just porn is the most disgusting in
the world like these poor girls on these
on these websites have been were like
raped as kids like they were usually
molested they've just been groomed into
this terrible industry to have SE like
have sex on C like it's just the most V
it it makes me want to throw up I can't
even look at like these female artists
singing about promiscuous stuff anymore
I can't even listen to it let alone jerk
oh it's just the most it's
disgusting so
horrible so guys you heard that for
yourself I mean look again um Can Gins
be homosexual I haven't heard anything
against it or that it cannot be I do not
know I believe that m to the scholars uh
but can Jin possess like you look at
look at a lot of people like Allah says
in the Quran if you forget my
remembrance I will make you forget your
own self you look at certain people and
be like why is this person like madon
you look at madon she looks like that
woman that man uh from uh the Saw movie
like she's flipping petrified like you
look at her face and thinking why would
one do that to their but it shows you
that when you forget Allah's remembrance
you forget your own self meaning you are
acting with no barriers like anything
goes you do mad stuff but you see people
who doing crazy Stu putting metal place
in their head you know these weird
looking people Etc and and even today's
woman like getting their lips done like
a balloon and you think to yourself why
would one do that to their and it goes
back to not remembering forgetting the
remance of Allah subhana that's what
Allah says in our remembrance do hearts
find peace and if you forget our
remebrance you will have a depressed
life so we know jins can possess and if
Gins can possess this is why we believe
all of these degeneracy and all these
sins be it whatever for us homosexuality
claiming you're a man or a woman or
whatever you know trans whatever
whatever whatever all of these things
start there pornography is the root of
all cause and funny enough all these
pornographic we websites ET are owned by
who zionists these are the individuals
who are perpetrating this filth and dirt
and we Muslims are the ones that are
hostile we the ones that are danger to
the Western World the Zionist are
destroying your youth your youth sonas
is an example of getting out of and
breaking the cycle and I myself as a as
a man who came to Islam knowing all that
disgusting degeneracy and all that
lifestyle that I lived to come out and
see the beauty of Islam and say
alhamdulillah as Muslims you guys do not
know how blessed you are to have Islam
now want to talk about for example these
things Shan comes to us Allah tells us
in the Quran in the verse in that
Allah's created us with inclination of
evil and good so they're both balanced
imagine two cups both balanced but the
one who purifies the evil yes Allah
tells the that the one who purifies evil
will be the successful so meaning that
we are all created when I was a
non-muslim I would get well I remember
times where I would get evil thoughts
and I can remember where I would like
there would be I I was so young but like
11 12 to harm like a pigeon like I
wanted to like literally harm a pigeon I
think to myself what the hell has a
pigeon done to me but it's this weird
when you do not have it from a young age
your Society prayer pressure evil is
that W I would have certain evil
inclinations and I did not know where
they come from I just did not know I'm
thinking to myself why am I thinking
like this why is these thoughts coming
in my head I understood when I came to
Islam you purify the soul the
remembrance of Allah the of Allah
subhana wa tala that's why doing your
son if you're watching this I'm going to
give an app is called the download this
do your morning and even do your free
course do your do not miss your is your
supplication from the evening and the
night it protects you against evil eye
black magic jealousy envy and even
possession and all this kind of stuff so
it's very important to do that have
Quran in your life do Quran I try my
best to have half an hour to 1 hour
Quran in my life if I read it I recite
it whatever it is in your life Quran is
a shif so brothers and sisters all of
these evil are there to attack you it's
the metaphysical world you cannot see
them but we need to understand that they
are real and they help they they attack
us break marriages Allah tells inah Bak
the first thing was used for what break
that breakdown of
marriages our family family members be
our friends whenever you see these
issues you ask ask yourself a question
what is your relationship with Allah
your Salah your your Quran if it's not
there then you need to question yourself
and say what if things are not going
right what am I doing wrong not oh
there's a problem with it must be Islam
No no no what are you doing wrong cuz
Islam is the H what Allah said is the H
what are you doing wrong always
self-reflect anytime you go through a
Calamity whatever internally look I try
to do this anytime something happens in
my life where I'm like why is going on I
reflect and say did I commit a sin did I
Wrong somebody what did I do and
self-reflect as well okay you know what
is the improvements I need to do yes
there is I self I don't look externally
and say everyone is wrong no they no
what AM am I doing wrong how's my
relationship with Allah how's my
relationship with the Quran how's my
relationship in general have I wronged
anybody have I been committing sins have
I been oppressed have I been wronging
myself and sometimes we wrong Allah
subhana wa tala we disobey Allah and
then we say oh why is this person not
disobeying me obeying me why is my wife
not respecting me why is my friend
disrespecting me why is this because
brother you don't have that obedience to
Allah the way you demand that respect
and that obedience from your family
members from your kids from your wife
from your your husband do you show the
same obedience to Allah no Allah is
showing you how you are disobedient to
me is how your wife will disobedient to
you or your husband will be disab or
your family member that's why the Sal
would say what if we go and commit a sin
not lower our gaze and look at somebody
we will come home and we see our wife
acting up and we say you know what
brother it's connected to the
Disobedience that I'm seeing the
Disobedience there so please understand
this correlations connection because it
all stems from there may Allah subh
protect son Faz keep him firm and strong
and be a means of calling people to
Islam inshallah and hope this benefited
you guys download the protect yourself
inah may Allah protect our families and
give us a good ending inam alayum